In my life as a professional engaged in
the business of education,
I frequently find myself involved in
conversations about college and career
readiness.
Almost always that phrase,
college and Career Readiness Precedes a
conversation between two people,
both of whom went to college,
a particular kind of college even,
and the conversation is usually about
college.
I think our society hasn't been serious
enough about the career part of that
equation.
There is a presumption among some people
that the body of knowledge necessary to
be ready for college level work and the
body of knowledge necessary to enter a
career with prospects for promotion are
exactly the same.
I believe that there are students,
in fact,
the vast majority of students whose
education after high school will look
nothing like mine.
I left my public high school in South
Carolina and moved to Massachusetts and
went to an ivy league university and
spent four years there,
graduated and went on with my career.
That is now an unusual experience to a
ridiculous extent except among education
policy people.
They're going to be many more students
who leave high school and go directly to
work and start on a path of learning
from work that's going to lead in very
different directions.
Then my career has led and I don't
believe that we have done enough at the
policy level to explore what those
different pathways might look like and
if you ask employers,
industry leaders,
they tend to agree with me on that.
We're not thinking enough about middle
skill jobs.
We're not thinking enough about
technical jobs below the level of
engineer and I think our society and
it's policy makers really need to pay
some careful attention to that.
Probably if if and when we start to pay
attention,
we will come upon the tragic absence of
apprenticeships in our American society
in Europe as many as a quarter to a half
of any group of teenagers at any any
point is pursuing an apprenticeship,
which means that they're getting both
academic training and work training
while being paid by an employer.
They are learning on the job to pursue a
particular career and that can be an
apprenticeship in software development.
It can be a PR,
an apprenticeship in hotel management.
It can be an apprenticeship in any
number of things in the states.
We have shamefully convinced most high
school students that they either need to
go to Harvard or they need to go to
Mcdonald's,
and the truth is significantly more
complicated than that in the middle of
where job growth growth is,
where there are jobs that are not being
filled today and too few people in our
public policy community are really
focused on what students who are going
to pursue a career as their pathway out
of poverty,
for example,
really need to be getting from their
education.
Really need to be getting from the
public policy people who are dedicated
to creating opportunities for them and
allowing them to pursue pathways that
look nothing like what we think is
traditional.
Because the reality is the notion that
you go off to college,
live in a dorm,
go to some football games,
graduate in four years and go on with
your life is a persistent myth that has
very little to do with the lives of most
people.
Uh,
pursuing a degree after high school
right now,
and the sooner we get to the point that
we take the career side of the college
and career readiness equation,
much more seriously,
the better off our society will be.
The fewer young people we will have who
were in a position of not being in
school or at work.
And the better off we will be in terms
of filling existing jobs,
requiring high levels of skills for
which there are no employees that.